exceeding expectations the strong
inflation-adjusted increase reflects the
resilience of the economy even in the
face of omicron compared to this time
last year sales at grocery stores
restaurants and clothing stores among
others increased underscoring the
strength of the american economy as we
recovered from the pandemic this data
builds on the historic economic progress
we've seen over the last year and an
extremely strong jobs report last month
despite omicron which was well above
expectations in 2021 the economy created
6.7 million jobs the strongest year of
job growth
the unemployment rate declined more than
any year on record and we achieved a
four percent unemployment rate years
earlier than previously projected thanks
to the american rescue plan small
business applications and inflated
inflation-adjusted households income are
both up and child poverty and hunger are
down we're obviously going to continue
to build on this progress
second uh today we're marking 60 days of
action strengthening america's trucking
workforce uh this is not just about um
recruitment but also retaining truckers
and to ensure we can move more goods
around the country and uh lower costs
for the american people over 70 percent
of all goods in america are shipped by
truck and america's trucking workflow
workforce plays a critical role in the
supply chain and the broader economy but
outdated infrastructure the pandemic and
a historic volume of goods moving
through our economy have strained
capacity across the supply chain
including and trucking two months ago
the president launched a multi-agency
effort to support and expand access to
quality truck driving jobs now and in
the year ahead and in the years ahead
while more uh work remains uh we have
made remarkable progress in the last 60
days we have expanded
registered apprenticeship programs we've
launched the safe driver apprenticeship
pilot to connect american adults under
21 to good paying jobs in the trucking
industry we've cut red tape so it's
easier for drivers to get commercial
driver's licenses and we've met with
veteran service organizations
representing nearly four million
veterans to discuss ways the
administration and industry can attract
train place and retain veterans in
trucking jobs
and we will announce the results of the
labor department's 90-day apprenticeship
program of course over the next after
the next 30 days this week secretary
beta judge will also sign the charter
document for the women of trucking
advisory board which will provide
recommendations to address challenges
facing women in trucking such as
barriers to entry on the job safety
risks workplace harassment mentorship
and more
finally very quick preview for the
president's trip to ohio tomorrow uh
it's been just 90 days since time flies
with the pres since the president
signed the bipartisan infrastructure law
and tomorrow he will be traveling to
lorraine ohio and deliver remarks on how
the bipartisan infrastructure law
delivers for the american people by
investing in cleanup and restoration
efforts in the great lakes region and
surrounding waterways these investments
will allow for a major acceleration of
progress that will deliver significant
environmental economic health and
recreational benefits for communities
throughout the region including helping
people in the community access clean
water
so those of you going to ohio now a
little more detail go ahead
darlene thank you uh juan are there any
plans being made for the president to
meet with republicans on the senate
judiciary committee as a group the same
way he met with democrats on the
committee last week sure so he's
continuing to engage with democrats and
republicans
about his uh pr his supreme court
process i don't have anything to preview
or project in terms of a meeting uh with
the senate judiciary republicans okay
second question is there a date for when
the president will send his fy 23 budget
proposal to the hill
i don't have a date either for you at
this point in time i think shalonda
young has conveyed it it was expected to
be after the state of the union and then
the last question is
with the vice president getting ready to
go to uh germany for the munich security
conference can you talk a little bit
about what her marching orders from the
president from the president are and
will she be going with any deliverables
or any concrete proposals specifically
to help europe deal with its energy and
natural gas
well she will be traveling as many of
you have been
following this no uh to munich germany
to attend the february 18th to 20th
munich security conference
she will build on the presidents and the
national security teams intensive
engagement with european allies and
partners uh and emphasize and continue
to emphasize with our partners our
ironclad commitment to our nato allies
underscore our commitment to ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and reinform our shared interest in
upholding the principles that have
underpinned european peace and security
she'll be participating in the formal
conference formal program of the
conference as well as engaging with
allies and partners and meeting with
leaders on the margins i know her team
is planning for a
preview call for all of you i believe
later this evening to give you more
details of those bilateral meetings but
i would say in terms of
her engagements and what the president
expects he expects and knows given she
is the first in the room and the last in
the room that she will continue to uh
convey to the rest of the world uh again
our ironclad commitment to our nato
allies our our commitment to defending
the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine and our
commitment to putting in place severe
economic consequences should russia
invade thank you
can you comment on uh russia's
investigation into claims of alleged
mass graves of civilians supposedly
killed by ukrainian forces in the
russian controlled regions in eastern
ukraine
do you believe this is part of the false
flag
operations that you've been warning of
sure well let me start by saying as you
heard the president say yesterday and
secretary blinken earlier today we're in
the window where we believe an attack
could come at any time and that would be
preceded by a fabricated pretext that
the russians use as an excuse to launch
an invasion and we've seen and we've
talked about this a bit in here we've
seen these tactics used
in the past
so those could include uh but not be
limited to the report you just
referenced
claims of crop provocation in donbass
fall state media reports which i think
you should all everybody should keep
their eyes open and aware of that
potential faked videos false accusations
about chemical weapons or accounts of
attacks on russian shoulders that have
not actually occurred so it there could
be a range of
false flags and pretext that we would
expect would
precede
an invasion and again we remain in that
window can you provide any update on the
intelligence assessment of who was
behind the cyber attacks of ukraine's
ministry of defense and certain banks
yesterday
continuous officials say that russia was
behind the attacks
we don't have any new details uh on an
attribution cyber attribution takes time
in part because adversaries usually try
to hide their tracks and it takes time
to gather and analyze relevant
information
and these can be these types of
incidents ddos incidents can be
particularly hard harder to trace
but we have also been
in close touch with our ukrainian
counterparts to offer support in the
investigation and response to these
incidents you may have seen the
statement from ukraine ministry of
defense that the united states and other
partners immediately reached out with
support and that some sites are coming
back online and i would note again as i
said yesterday we've been warning for
months both publicly and privately in
our engagements with ukrainians and the
europeans that uh the potential for
russia to conduct cyber operations in
ukraine
is part of their playbook uh as well so
we're particularly concerned but we
don't have anything new in terms of
specific attribution oh go ahead okay
are you done
didn't we interrupt i'm so polite
secretary of state lincoln today said
that
he has seen evidence that vladimir putin
is actually moving critical military
assets toward the border with ukraine
and not away from the border as putin
has claimed so does the administration
believe that putin is actually
escalating this crisis in real time well
i think as secretary blinken also said
um the russian troops remain masked in a
very threatening way at the border and
he was responding i believe to a
question a good question about whether
they were delivering on what they had
promised yesterday and the answer was no
uh there's you know what russia says and
there's what russia does and we're
watching very closely uh what steps
they're taking but they remain amassed
in a threatening way at the border
there's not yet been
to our awareness an actual invasion this
date had been circled on the calendar as
one that this administration that other
governments worldwide were watching very
close with what do you make of the fact
that at this point
it is now darkness in that region
there hasn't been a military invasion
well kristen without getting into any
intelligence or or conversations we
would have with allies or partners uh
what we had conveyed last week and you
heard jake sullivan convey very clearly
is that we were in the window we remain
in the window
is there still as much hope for
diplomacy today is there more hope where
does that thinking stand we of course
the door continues to be open to
diplomacy uh secretary blinken spoke
with foreign minister lavrov yesterday
uh jake sullivan speaks with his
ukrainian counterpart nearly every day
if not every day we remain the president
of course is going to speak with central
schultz later this afternoon so there
are it is moving forward uh diplomatic
conversations on many channels follow up
to a question you got yesterday about a
potential gas tax holiday you said all
options were on the table can you go a
little further are there actually
discussions going on between the white
house and democrats on capitol hill
about moving forward with the gas tax
holiday i also said yesterday new
decisions have been made and that
remains the case so we always have an
open dialogue with
members of congress and all options
remain on the table go ahead uh one
housekeeping thing first um speaking of
secretary blinken he was at an event
earlier today here in town and said he
was cutting his time short there in
order to have a meeting with the boss
the president was something added to the
schedule this afternoon or
was there something
coming um without knowing the details of
the secretary's schedule i think the
president had the pdb this morning so it
may have been that i can check if
there's anything different than that um
beyond that um
foreign minister lavrov told secretary
plinkin yesterday
that russia's response to the u.s nato
proposals would be transmitted in the
coming days
has it been received or is this
potentially
productive or seen as a possible delay
well we look forward to receiving it as
secretary blinken has conveyed as of my
knowledge before i came out uh for this
briefing i think we are still waiting
for that
is there any update on the us assessment
of the video released by russia claiming
to show some tanks ending military
drills through ukraine was a lot of
concern about whether this was legit has
there been any determination that it is
uh i i don't have any new assessment of
that ed i think what uh we are watching
very closely is uh not just what they
say but what they do i understand you're
referencing a video but we've also seen
as the secretary confirmed this morning
uh continued uh problematic troubling uh
build up of troops at the border and
surrounding ukraine i'm not going to ask
you if the president's meeting today or
soon with supreme court nominee what if
i answered what if i was prepared to
answer it today
you're missing out
i am not going to provide a day by day
update ed i just had to mess with you
there a little bit
i am curious i am curious this is a
president who's been a participant in
this for
decades he knows that in the run-up to a
decision there is a public campaign
there's sort of a background lobbying
effort by people close to
nominees there's some of that going on
in this case uh what does he make i'm
not commenting specifically on anyone's
story or letter sent or anything but
what does he make of that
attempt to influence an administration
as they make a decision and does he
welcome it or does he
see it if it gets a little too
personal perhaps or petty
is detrimental to the process well i
think uh because of the president's long
history and long background you
referenced as the former chairman of the
judiciary committee as the former vice
president i believe he's probably
overseen or been engaged with more
supreme court nominee processes than
anyone in history uh he is not going to
be swayed by public campaigns or public
sniping or
lobbying efforts he is going to pick an
eminently qualified black woman to
nominate to the supreme court he has a
number of
potential choices that he's very excited
about real quick
on this
the club for growth is now running ads
in english and in spanish
targeting latino audiences and
suggesting that the president's focus on
nominating a black woman to the court
versus qualified latino judges in the
list of human rights is racist
what do you make of that
well the supreme court has been around
for 230 years there's never been a black
woman who served on the supreme court
the president believes that's a problem
with past processes and not a lack of
qualified black women to serve on the
supreme court uh there are also
opportunities perhaps in the future
we'll see to nominate others we don't
know at this point in time but the
president is
proud of the range of credible qualified
candidates he's looking at and looking
forward to making an announcement soon
thank you
a quick follow-up on the cyber stuff
will the u.s consider a disruptive
attack against russia similar to the
ddos one right now being made against
you
so say that more time i'm sorry if the
us would consider like a distributed
denial of service attack like what is
talked about potential cyber responses
is that one of the potential options
in terms of what we would do in response
yes i i'm not going to outline or detail
what options the president would have as
his disposal again he uh can take any
step
seen and unseen uh he has the the right
to do that but we have not even made an
attribution at this point in time
russia's lower house of parliament voted
on tuesday to ask putin to recognize the
self-declared donetsk and luhans
people's republics
lincoln said today that that move would
necessitate a swift and firm response
from the united states in full
coordination with allies and partners
what might such a response look like
sanctions export controls what kind of
there's a range of options we have at
our disposal i'm not going to outline
those from here but i would also just
reiterate a couple of points that
secretary blinken made in his statement
which includes the fact that the
kremlin's support of this
amounts to the russian government's
wholesale rejection of its commitments
its own commitments under the minsk
agreement uh which uh is certainly the
reason to have such a strong reaction to
it from the secretary of state an
enactment further undermines ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
constituting a gross violation of
international law uh so hence we have as
you said he he conveyed in his statement
that necessitates a swift and firm
response from the united states in full
coordination with our allies and
partners but i don't have anything to
preview at this point in time quick
follow-up on oil um cnn is reporting
that nsc middle east coordinator brett
mcgurk and state department energy envoy
amos
are in reality thank you
just to restate his name on television
amos um uh are we out today to press the
saudis to plumber or oil i wondered if
you could confirm that
i can confirm there on a trip there are
a range of topics to discuss including
yemen and as you know we
engaging with our partners around the
world about ensuring supply meets demand
is part of our objective from here as
well and that's one of the objectives of
the meeting as well i don't have more
details on the meeting at this point in
time go ahead thanks jen the secretary
of state said today that they've not
seen meaningful pullback by russia when
it comes to the forces that they put on
ukraine's border what would meaningful
pullback look like to the united states
well i'm not going to define that by
troop numbers i think we will know it
when we see it which is a
verifiable uh reduction of troops at the
border of ukraine so you're not looking
at a certain metric or anything like
that nothing that i'm going to outline
from here
um the president updated the number
yesterday changing it from about 130
000. we believed that russia had a mouse
on the border to closer to 150 000
how long does the united states believe
russia can maintain that kind of a
forced posture well he also said uh
including in belarus and and circling
ukraine as well to be clear in terms of
their ability to maintain that i'm not
going to get into intelligence from here
but there's no judgment on nothing i'm
going to outline from here okay my last
question on the cia station is being
relocated closer to the border with
poland outside of kiev
does the u.s have concerns that that
will affect their ability to be able to
track russia's movements from ukraine a
lot of intelligence questions today
which is absolutely fine but i there's
nothing i can detail on that from here
either no concern that the moving the
cia station out of the capital is going
to i'm just not going to speak about our
intelligence processes in ukraine or in
the surrounding area from here
uh go ahead thanks and um
obviously the invasion didn't happen
today the pentagon was eyeing today as a
possible date that somebody could see
some sort of action um some sort of
invasion does the white house think that
putin could be bluffing
about what about his intention to
not invade or to envy well either way
well president putin has said he doesn't
intend to invade
we've also said he's prepared uh he's
prepared uh to do that and has lined up
troops at the border uh to to invade so
uh i don't think we're uh we are waiting
for president putin's comments to assess
what is being prepared around the border
do you think that your efforts to put
all this intelligence out um about his
you know what might happen next might
have deterred
something that we could have seen in the
last 24 hours well that's part of our
object has been part of our objective
overall jackie right is to make it more
difficult for uh the russians for
president putin to uh to lay a predicate
for war to when our objective is to try
to avoid war prevent war now it's
ultimately up to president putin to
decide what steps he's going to take but
putting out specific details about the
types of false flag operations their
efforts to push misinformation through
russian media uh the types of
tactics they've used in the past that's
all a part of our effort to make it more
difficult for them to use these tactics
and keep the eyes of the global
community open
this whole standoff underscored the
importance of nato allies spending uh
two percent of their gdp toward defense
is that something that the white house
will be pressing in the future from our
allies that's something that uh the uh
president pressed for when he was vice
president and i asked about a second
topic the durham investigation
durham says there was an outside company
with ties to the clinton camp uh
monitoring server data info on the
executive office of the president
through the obama administration
possibly into the trump administration
uh do you know if there's still a system
picking up
server data on the eop and if not
when it stopped again i know you asked
my colleague a few questions about this
the other day but i would point you any
questions about this the department of
justice and then is what was described
in the filing there
monitoring internet traffic is that
generally speaking would that be
considered something
along the lines of spying again i
appointed the department of justice go
ahead
thanks is that you as confident at this
point that all intelligence and
sensitive material has been removed and
destroyed from the u.s embassy in caves
there's obviously steps every embassy
takes when they move or relocate but i'm
not going to get into those details from
here i'd point to the state department
if there's more they'd like to share and
oil prices are nearing a hundred dollars
a barrel at some milestone that hasn't
reached since 2014.
what steps is the administration taking
at this point to deal with high oil
prices i haven't been talking to allies
about a coordinated global release of
oil we have been in touch with allies
and partners suppliers uh out there on
the global stage for weeks now uh in
preparation for a range of impacts of
you know in anticipation of an invasion
or actually an impact of an invasion
both for natural gas and oil
prices on the market we will continue
those engagements of course as i've said
and i said yesterday
for the president all options remain on
the table as you know in the past or
recent months he tapped the strategic
petroleum reserve 50 million barrels
those have been released over the course
or 40 million of them i think to date
have been released over the course of
time we also remain of course engaged
with congress and uh and countries
around the world about how to meet the
demands out there one more the president
urged congress as we act on gun control
at the anniversary of parkland shooting
it's been five months now since david
chipman's nomination was withdrawn
what's the current timetable for
nominating ftf director well we
certainly would love to have an atf
director in place for the first time and
i think a decade uh someone confirmed
and unfortunately obviously david
chipman was eminently qualified for the
position and uh was not able to move
forward and the president would like to
nominate someone uh to replace him but i
don't have anything on the timeline good
in an effort to pry the window open a
bit wider into the president's thinking
on the supreme court sure
what is the thinking here about some of
the pushback that's been
aired on the left with respect to judge
michelle childs in south carolina
that criticism did she he was too or has
human
queued
too closely to uh corporations
well i think with some of the criticism
i've seen out there is related to her
labor record if you look at south
carolina the afl in south carolina
endorsed her
and has been supportive of her i think
the president in response er just to go
back to ed's question which i think is
similar um the president is not uh
interested in public griping uh or in
lobbying campaigns or efforts to trash
other candidates he is going to
keep his blinders on look at the
qualifications the cases the backgrounds
the credentials of these eminently
qualified nominees all of the ones he's
considering would make excellent uh
qualified supreme court justices and
that's where his focus remains
background in qualifications how
important is it to the president that
his choice have served as a public
defender
again i'm not going to get into any more
specifics of the qualifications you have
a short window left before you will know
probably who he is uh selected um and
you will have more i'm sure analysis to
do at that time go ahead thanks chad on
the uh stalled fed nominations in the
banking committee uh chairman brown uh
said today uh that he's refusing to move
the other picks um separate from
sarah bloom raskin
he also said that he spoke to president
biden and that president behind this
standing
by senate democrats on this so um is the
white house backing that strategy of
holding all the nominees up and
essentially waiting for republicans to
show up at the banking committee to vote
absolutely and i was in the oval office
when the president spoke with senator
brown uh so i can confirm not that there
was any doubt that he conveyed exactly
that to the senator that
he
agrees that republicans are awol on the
fight against inflation and this at this
pivotal moment in our economy everyone
understands we need a full federal
reserve board uh the first one in nearly
a decade to tackle and face inflation
and bring prices down for american
families so no
we are not advocating for splitting the
nominees we support
chairman brown's decision to keep all
five on the fed board
pushing them forward through the
committee and we believe republicans
need to do their jobs
and show up to vote for these nominees
spoken about the urgency with inflation
and other issues facing the fed uh but
given that republicans have shown no
signs of pending and that the senate is
poised to go on recess by the end of the
week i mean how likely or unlikely is it
that we're going to see a vote before
the end of the month on these nominees
well i would point you to chairman brown
for that um he is uh very committed uh
and i'm sure and then i think as you've
seen him publicly can be quite a bulldog
when he wants to get something done so
uh we support his efforts to get these
five nominees forward there's a couple
uh days left and all we're asking is for
republicans to show up and do their job
they can vote against people uh or but
not showing up is not as not is not
delivering on the commitment you made to
the american people and they elected you
lastly on that issue senator timmy was
at an event where he said you believe
the fed was basically able to perform at
full strength even without the confirmed
nominees your reaction to that i think
there's no question that having a full
uh federal
board um fighting inflation at a time
where that is the stated number one
concern of many republicans many
democrats and many uh in the american
public would be the ideal scenario here
said a couple times just now that the
president is not going to be swayed by
lobbying efforts but i'm wondering if
that's the case what does he make of
congressman clyburn's pretty aggressive
push for one specific judge says child
does that count as lobbying is the
president listening to that this is
obviously someone he has a high esteem
and is close with of course he does uh
he has him in high esteem he is close
with him but again the president who is
someone who has been through a number of
these processes before who's overseen
hearings who has played a role as vice
president and helping select uh
incredible nominees and now supreme
court justices to serve uh he's going to
consult broadly uh and then he's going
to look at their credentials review
cases and make a decision about the
right person to nominate for the court i
think the only other angle left on the
interviews that you have not been asked
is will you tell us when the interviews
are complete
unlikely i will tell you
the president will tell you when there's
a nominee the good news is march 1st is
around the corner so you know we remain
on track and you don't have too much
longer to wait go ahead
thanks uh last night uh voters in san
francisco voted to recall through school
board members i'm wondering if the white
house has any reaction to that result
sure we of course uh did see that um we
don't have any reaction directly to the
decision by the local school board but i
would just reiterate that the
president's objective has been keeping
schools open uh from the beginning and
now at this point in time 99 of schools
are open in large part because of the
funding in the american rescue plan and
efforts that he and his secretary of
education undertook to ensure schools
had the resources and the information
needed to keep schools open we
understand where parents are coming from
when they want schools to be open as
well and the president recognizes the
mental health impact it has on for them
not to be open so
we may specific comment on the law
school the local decision about the
local school board leaders but that
remains the president's objective and on
education more broadly we saw that be an
issue in the virginia gubernatorial race
obviously this is the issue here in san
francisco i'm wondering what the white
house or the president's message is to
parents about
you address school reopening but more
broadly some of the issues that we've
seen play about equity about uh
curriculum play
in some of these electoral races well
tell me more about specifically
specifically there was controversy over
the renaming of schools um they're in in
virginia conversations about critical
race theory um i'm wondering whether the
the white house or the president thinks
that some of these school boards maybe
in san francisco and other places have
moved too far to the left adopted
liberal policies beyond you know
seemingly uh approve of or just more
generally how the president thinks of uh
of education and some of these these
issues around equity and inclusion
well i would say first that uh the
president is married to a teacher uh so
he certainly trusts in
the role of teachers and educators
across the country and uh the kind of
curriculum that they are providing i'm
not going to have any specific comment
on any local school board or the
politics of school boards as it relates
to any political race either though
okay go ahead
thanks jen um going back to the senate
banking committee would the white house
support a rule change to allow the
senate majority to discharge a
nomination directly from committee as
they do with legislation i believe that
i would really point you to chairman
brown's team in office i think they have
spoken to this and conveyed i don't
think that there is a path forward for
that but i would point you to them for
any comment
yesterday's um secretary of state
anthony lincoln said that he was quote
troubled by new charges that are being
brought against russian activists
alexander
um would the white house consider um in
consultation with its allies potentially
sanctions on individual leaders maybe in
putin's circle to stop this or other
efforts that you all could do to
help navalny and the russian opposition
there are a range of sanctions under
consideration on his inner circle
and then finally congressional democrats
again are talking about student loan
cancellation
alexandria cassio cortez discussed this
um earlier this week and um senate
majority leader chuck schumer has also
talked about the importance of canceling
student loan debt um why is this not an
issue that with broad public support and
support within its own party in congress
has the president not worked or pushed
for harder on to counsel well the
president has conveyed he'd be happy to
sign a bill into law that all of those
members could work to get passed
finally um
yesterday mark's the 30th house democrat
to announce their retirement from
congress um is the house of concern that
this is indicative of a political
climate in the broader country in his
own party um and could simply the
retirements of very senior democrats on
the hill potentially have implications
for the white house's domestic agenda
well as you know i have to be a little
careful i've learned i've learned my
lesson the hard way uh about talking
about politics from up here uh there are
a range of retirements uh every cycle
for a variety of reasons um and what
we're focused on is
working with members to deliver for the
american people and
we expect that anyone who's going to be
out there
answering questions to people who may
vote for them in the future that they
will hopefully talk about the work
they've done with the president to
create the greatest 12 months of job
creation our nation's history the
largest drop in unemployment rate on
record the largest reduction in
childhood poverty ever the strongest
economic growth this country has seen in
nearly 40 years so uh there's a lot
we're going to be focused on uh the
president himself is conveyed he's
looking forward to being out there uh
when it's time for a political season
but uh beyond that i'm a little limited
in what i can convey from here go ahead
i actually do have something okay one
thing um
the uh i think circling back to
something i think we asked corinne about
a couple of days ago but
the mayor of the district of columbia
has has announced that she's going to
significantly reduce the restrictions
the code restrictions indoor mask
wearing i think comes off at the end of
the month uh the requirement to show
uh proof of vaccination has ended i
think as of yesterday
the campus the white house campus is in
washington dc obviously like affected by
the metrics that are
around in terms of case counts and
hospital accounts and what have you um
you know does does that
are you guys going to
follow
some of the the recommendations that the
mayor has put out or are you going to
wait for the cdc
to make their recommendations before you
change any of the activities on this
campus we'll wait for the cdc uh and
they've said and i know you had a
coveted briefing a little bit earlier
today that they're continuing to review
mass guidelines and how different
communities in the country should assess
them but we'll wait for the cdc to make
any changes here and on the supreme
court i i think i've thought of one more
way okay go ahead go ahead which is only
to say that when the president said the
other day that
he was considering about four
nominees did he mean three
did about four mean three
the president the president meant about
four and i don't have anything further
to add to that go ahead i'm sorry i
actually do have another way sure
go ahead go ahead with the president
traveling tomorrow
could we could you rule out that the
announcement would come this week and
would you flush out more details on what
you expect the announcement to look like
sometimes we've seen them take place in
prime time with events in the east room
is that what the president's looking out
for his announcement we don't have any
details on that to preview at this point
in time
i appreciate it go ahead and on the
state of california a couple of
california themed questions for you so
the epa is finalizing a rule that would
give california a waiver uh to the
authority to set its own emissions
standards
why does the administration think it's
important for california to have the
ability to set its own emission
standards
uh this is a great question i know i
have something on this um but i don't
have it in front of me so let me get you
it's you after the briefing absolutely
and uh to follow up on that though even
with the waiver california is expected
largely to stick to the biden
administration standards but the
president has indicated in the past that
he does look to california on these
issues so if california were to
institute stricter standards stay on uh
either heavy duty vehicles for instance
would that be something that the
administration would seriously consider
mirroring
it's a good question but i don't have
anything to predict or preview on that
front obviously the president's
objective remains uh lowering emissions
in the country and reaching his uh
ambitious climate goals that he's set uh
but in terms of what future stat steps
look like i don't have anything to
project at this point
but not on a mission okay okay president
biden has been supportive of governor
gavin newsom in many instances does he
support governor newsom's decisions to
drop the universal mass mandate in
california even as mass continue to be
required in california schools well
there are a number of states who've made
decisions not just california and
announcements and what we've said and i
can repeat is that
we will continue to
look for and abide by cdc guidance from
the federal government that's what we
will follow but different leaders will
make decisions based on what they think
is best for their communities
go ahead great thank you
one more on skoda so okay
go ahead is it it is a new
tactical maneuver
um
senator grassley the ranking republican
on the judiciary committee today told
reporters on the hill that he is under
the impression that president feiden is
doing interviews this week can you
confirm or deny what senator grassley
said we said as early as this week
that's all the detail i have for you
afghanistan this week marks six months
since the withdrawal from afghanistan
um from this podium jake sullivan told
us that the commitment to allies there
is sacrifice
the administration committed to doing
everything it could to get our allies
out but tens of thousands of allies
hundreds of thousands of you include
families including siv people in the
pipeline are still there and struggling
what exactly is the administration doing
to get them out because on the ground
and from congress my sources say
they think you're doing nothing
well i would say that we have
successfully helped uh i can get you the
specific number but i believe it's
hundreds um depart from afghanistan
partners allies people who have stood by
our side since we withdrew from
afghanistan at the end of august we've
worked in partnership with allies and
partners in the region including the
cutteries where we have our diplomatic
presence we are the largest contributor
of humanitarian assistance
of any country in the world which we
continue to provide through uh through
proven third-party aid organizations as
well and uh flights just resumed i think
a couple of weeks ago uh
through cuttery airways and that will
also play a role in helping but we
remain committed to working with our
partners in the region and to um helping
those who want to leave afghanistan who
have been serving by our side for 20
years to help do that could you help me
i can follow up get numbers on women in
particular
i would point to the state department
and they have they would have any
details on specific numbers go ahead
thank you um the british prime minister
said that russia is sending signal
signals or messages
they said they opened for diplomacy and
they keep on building the military back
up on the border the zoe does believe
actually that the russians are using
deceitful tactics and can you update us
on the talks in vienna um or iran talks
do you think that we're closer to
getting a deal you yourself said that
february is a vital month if this is
crunch time
so on the first question uh you know as
secretary blinken said this morning
there is what russia says and then
there's what russia does and we
certainly believe that
they will continue to use false flag
operations
efforts to deceive lay a predicate for
war which is why we have been putting
out as much information as we can on
that front so that uh the world is aware
and knows what to look for and watch for
and we do that of course in partnership
uh with our allies around the world as
it relates to iran
they i believe they're still in the
eighth round of negotiations um you know
of course as we've said in the past um
you know we would certainly support
efforts or the opportunity to have
direct uh engagement with the iranians
um we um won't
we've said that a deal our focus remains
on a deal that addresses the core
concerns of all sides um and if it's not
reached in the coming weeks as we've
said before but this remains the case
iran's ongoing nuclear advances will
make it impossible for us to return to
the jcpoa so
bottom line is under the jcpoa iran's
program was tightly constrained and
monitored by international inspectors
since the previous administration seized
u.s participation iran has rapidly
accelerated and reduced cooperation um
and that is hence why we are where we
are uh but we uh they they are
continuing to engage
of my last update on this uh but again
i'd reiterate that the president has to
team to present or to to put together a
range of options in the event those need
to be considered okay
go ahead yes thanks uh so on monday was
the one year anniversary of the phase
one trade deal with china going into
effect
um written into that deal is very
specific enforcement language um so when
does the administration trigger that
language against china because they
haven't lived up to that agreement
well so
the phase one trade agreement that uh
the president i think you're i think
that's not exactly accurate as my
understanding of what the status of this
is at this point or what anything that's
triggered or not triggered uh the
automatic trigger but but there is
specific language in there as to what
the enforcement is
well so first um you know when he was
running for president uh the president
made clear the phase one deal did not
address the core problems with china's
state-led economy and harmful economic
practices uh ustr since that period of
time has been making a concerted effort
to see if china will show serious intent
to make good on their purchase
commitments but the fact that they have
not met those
illustrates the limitations of the
framework we inherited they're still in
discussions about them um so i don't
have kind of an update on that i would
leave that to uh catherine tyre
ambassador is there a sense of urgency
now that china and russia are moving
closer together well that has been the
case for some time now um it also does
not change the fact that uh if russia
were to invade the the uh the size and
seriousness of the economic consequences
and package that's not something that
china would have the ability to uh fill
in the gaps on thanksgiving okay oh oh
yes i gotta go really wanna do the last
one thank you
climate change conditions of topic
according to a report published
yesterday by 2050 the sea level on u.s
coast uh would rise by one foot which
means 40 percent of american people who
live in coastal areas would see more
damaging
floods what is the administration doing
about it and does the president feel
he's doing enough to fight climate
change well you've heard the president
say time and time again especially when
he goes and visits
communities that have been impacted by
major weather events one in three
americans live in a county hit by a
weather disaster this past year which is
a pretty startling uh statistic and last
year extreme weather cost america 99
billion dollars so we know we know
climate change is real anyone who doubts
it that's further evidence climate
change is real and it's exacerbating the
extreme weather uh conditions and
certainly this report is further
evidence of that what the president has
done is of course work to pass the
bipartisan infrastructure law which a
lot of people focus on roads rails and
bridges important parts but it also has
an enormous investment in strengthening
our nation's resilience to extreme
weather and climate change while
reducing greenhouse gas emissions
replacing lead pipes so everyone has
access to clean water and we've also
been mobilizing an olive government
approach to deploy and implement
critical clean energy projects but i
would also note uh that this is one of
the reasons the president is going to
continue to press for uh
key components of his
agenda his build back better agenda
including historic investment in
addressing the climate crisis thanks
everyone see you tomorrow